if you've ever been stung by a jellyfish
you know that their sting can pack a
mean punch that stinger is actually a
tiny missile launched from a cell on the
jelly's tentacle both microbes and
cnidarians such as jellyfish wield these
harpoon like weapons called
'no man assists microbes like
dinoflagellates have evolved their own
arsenal of these tiny weapons this is
Polly Creek Oska 40 hunting for dinner
we've known for almost a hundred years
of these miniscule creatures were
hunting and fighting with weapons but
thanks to new technology we can now
observe them in stunning detail using
focused ion beam scanning microscopy
researchers imaged and model two
different dinoflagellates they found
that the romanticists are surprisingly
sophisticated
when compared to the animal counterparts
even though jellyfish no man assists are
twenty times larger they have far fewer
moving parts in Pali Creek goska 40 each
to mitosis is made up of a capsule with
a stylet nestled inside when they sense
their preys Within Reach
they fire off the stylet bursting
through the upper Coulomb and literally
tow their catch in to eat then the
towline dissolves researchers also
studied another type of planet flatly
that employed a Gatling gun with 10 to
15 skylights arranged in a circle
despite the similarity to nomads assists
found in jellyfish and its relatives one
is not derived from the other they
evolved independently in fact the
ancestors of dinoflagellates were
photosynthetic relying on the power of
the Sun to create energy over time they
lost their ability to harness the sun's
energy and became full-time hunters now
they've spent millennia honing their
weapons gearing up their Gatling guns
and gathering their defensive you
[Music]